- When I go for something,
I go for it at the expense
of everything else.
I always trust my gut, that's all I have.
Everything is possible
and nothing is guaranteed.
- Hello, believe nation, it's
Evan, my one word is believe
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope
is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from actor and producer Tom Hiddleston
and my take on his top
10 rules to success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(upbeat music)
- I don't know that I've ever
been able to do anything.
I say it as a sort of,
because I'm aware that
it can be a strength
but it can also be a weakness
because the focus is obsessive
and so when I go for something,
I go for it at the expense
of everything else.
And I love what I do, simply,
and I feel so lucky that
I'm allowed to do it
and that I get to do it for a living
and cinema and theater have had
such a profound effect on me
in my life.
It's just a gut feeling.
I think I always trust my gut,
that's all I have, even when I'm working
and you're thinking about
the shape of a scene
and how it should be played
and your head can often get in the way
and you've got to trust your gut.
And it's just if I'm inspired,
if my curiosity is peaked,
and I want to chase this possibility down,
that I see in front of me on my desk,
and some of you may have
heard me say this before
and I'm embarrassed to say
I always speak in metaphors,
I don't know how to speak in any other way
and for me, acting is kind
of like playing the piano
and if the piano is the human condition
and we all have every single note
on that 88 key board within us
and for me, every role, I want
to be able to play every note
and sometimes if a character or a story
seem to stretch me in some way,
seems to offer up an
experience that is new,
that is a different chord
or a different tune,
that is real and true
and human and accessible
and no matter how joyous or loving or warm
or how dark or painful,
if it seems like an
interesting shape to inhabit,
I know if I'm running towards it already.
Okay, couple of basic things,
be on time,
never underestimate the
importance of punctuality,
be prepared,
you can never be overprepared
and be true to yourself
and if you have something
that you want to say
that you've been burning to say,
don't ever let anyone tell
you that you can't say it.
Everything is possible
and nothing is guaranteed.
And you start auditioning
and if you're lucky
enough you have an agent
and you start auditioning
and they send you everything
from period drama to casualty
to dairy milk commercials,
yep, I went up for a diary
milk commercial when I was 24
and you are thrown into the bus
and thrown into the deep end
and there's no time for doubt or failure
except routinely that's
what happens to all of us
and I perhaps was too
careful in auditioning
and I would always get
close to landing roles
and to booking jobs
and I would never quite get there.
I mean, this is a universal experience
for all creative people, certainly actors,
is the constant rejection at the beginning
and you have to get used to it
and you have to get thick skinned about it
and I got so exhausted by,
I was trying to sort of
'cause at first you
take it very personally
and I thought well, no one's
going to help me get there,
the only person who can do this is me
and I started preparing in a different way
and I sort of stepped up to
the plate a little better,
I think
because I could feel time sliding away
and I wasn't getting on with life,
I just was sort of stuck in this rut
of neither acting nor doing anything else.
And the experience of being
in your 20's is so energetic,
and I felt so stagnant, actually
so I just kind of changed
everything up and it worked.
I think a myth in the business
is that we all have
everything to choose from.
We don't.
I know I'm not the top
of everybody's list.
No, but that's not it,
you have to earn that place.
Matt Damon used to say
every script that he got
he knew it had Brad Pitt's
fingertips all over it
and mine just happen to be
Michael Fassbenders, that's okay.
No listen, he's an amazing actor,
really, truly gifted
and that was kind of a joke.
Every actor is completely different
but you know, sometimes you
might read something and think,
I have read things and
gone, wow this is amazing
and I've chased it down
and knocked on the door
and people have said, "It's not you, Tom,"
or, "We're thinking of someone different."
And then my job is to keep
knocking on the door and say,
"Let me see if I can change your mind."
I think the most enjoyable
thing about acting for me
is when I sense that in pushing myself
and challenging myself
to explore new territory,
when you make a connection with people,
when people tell you that
they've been moved by something
or that they related to something,
it's about connection
and I find it stems
from my own passion as an audience member
is I remember my world being changed,
the way I saw the world,
I remember it being changed
by films and by theater.
The day that I saw One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest,
I couldn't stop thinking
about it for weeks
and I think cinema and theater
and the same is true,
I've told this story before
but I went to see a production
of John Gabriel Borkman
at the National Theater when I was 14
and it's the last time that
Paul Scofield was on stage
and he was with Vanessa
Redgrave and Eileen Atkins
and I saw, I was very conscious
of an audience of strangers
arriving at the National Theater
after a day of doing
whatever they were doing,
doing their job,
coming from all quarters
of the city to London,
to the home of the
theater on the South Bank,
having a drink, catching up,
rushing in, taking their seats,
the lights going down
and three hours later,
the entire theater sobbing,
wiping away the same tears
in recognition of the same grief
which is universal
and feeling like Paul
Scofield, particularly,
had spoken to my experience
and I had never met him
and I'll always be
grateful to him for that
and so that's what I love about it really
is that as I say acting connects people,
that's what I enjoy.
And so I always,
every time a new script
or a new role comes along,
I'm motivated by the thought
that I won't forgive myself
if I don't give it everything.
But I do try to choose
different kinds of things
because I'm interested in
the diversity of people
and the complexity of people
and the multiplicity we contain within us.
I really think the thing that
unites us all in the world
is that we are constantly inconstant
and that inconstancy
and that contradiction
is something that I've
always tried to explore
with my characters
because I think we do things that,
we contradict ourselves all the time.
There's the Walt Whitman
poem, The Song of Myself,
"I am large, I contain
multitudes, I contradict myself."
Learning is the leg work,
anyone who's been in
anything, a play or a film,
that's our job, we have to
get these words into our head
and I can't sit down,
literally I can't sit
down and read something
and just learn it by rote.
I have to be on the move.
So I tend to just,
I'm the deranged guy in London
who's walking around
pretending he's on the phone,
but actually I'm speaking
in iambic pentameter
'cause I'm learning Shakespeare.
And it's literally just
repetition, repetition, repetition,
you kind of drill it into yourself.
It's like learning,
I always say that you
have to know the text
as well as you know Happy Birthday.
If someone asks you
to sing a jazzy version of
Happy Birthday you'd know
because you know how Happy Birthday goes
or if they ask you to
do it like Beethoven,
you'd be able to do that.
And it has to be in your body
with as much kind of confidence as that.
So it's just repetition really.
Compassion is about understanding.
Compassion is without ego,
if that's possible for
actors, I don't know.
As an actor, to have
compassion as an actor
is to have compassion for
the characters that I play.
That's what it means to me.
And whatever they're going through,
whatever their predicaments,
I have to suffer with them.
I have to understand,
I have to not judge it.
I have to be forgiving of it,
whether it's a circumstance
or their true nature,
to have compassion for
another human being,
to have compassion for a character
is notdifferent from having compassion
for another human being.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
It was an event in Seoul, in South Korea
and I was there with the film
and we were, there was a big event
and there was several
thousand people there
in a big shopping center
called Times Square
and I was taking some questions on stage
and somebody asked in what body part
are you most confident in?
Which I thought was a new question,
one that I hadn't been asked before
and so I thought the most innocuous answer
was to say my feet
because without my feet I couldn't run
and I love running
and also I couldn't
dance and I love dancing.
So then they said, "Well, now
we have to see you dance."
So I thought, oh my God,
I've walked right into this
but it was fun.
(upbeat music)
- Someone told me about it and I was like,
"Oh no, what's he done?"
He's a really good dancer, incredible.
Was that rehearsed?
That was not an improvised
dance, that one.
Check it out.
- I'd like to see that, he's amazing.
- He's really got it,
he's really got it.
He's adorable.
(upbeat music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video
because TellingItLikeItIs
2000 asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in a future top 10,
please check out the link
down in the description below
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Tori.
Tori, thank you so much for
picking up one of my tee shirts,
the rebel tee shirt,
it looks great on you
and I hope you're enjoying wearing it out.
Thank you for sharing the
picture on Instagram for me
and to your audience as well.
I really appreciate the support.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(audience laughter)
- Don't miss this.
Does this work out here?
Okay.
(blowing into microphone)
(audience cheering)
(breathing into microphone)